guys hello how are you welcome to my
birthday celebration video I'm
celebrating my birth here with you it's
also mr. Rogers birthday and if some of
you guys don't know who mr. Rogers is
we're not even gonna go there the reason
that I'm making this video is because I
well because it's Wednesday and I make
videos pretty much every Wednesday a lot
of you guys know that I'm absolutely
obsessed with so so happy they make all
those dinosaur hoodies and I'm actually
not wearing one right now because I got
to do my laundry yesterday I went and
had a meeting was so so happy because
I'm obsessed with them and they said
come see our office him see all their
cool stuff so I did and then as I was
leaving I somehow said something about
it's my birthday tomorrow they're like
yeah we have party supplies everybody I
want to show you my party supplies that
I just got his box is full of still so
having party supplies because I'm gonna
have a so so happy birthday party
tonight and it's gonna be sort of like a
not a fancy restaurant but I don't think
they're gonna be prepared for my party
decorations little so so happy
centerpiece here now what else oh yes oh
not just one so so happy centerpiece who
knew oh hey there's different things on
each side whole party is going to be
complete without napkins there you go
one for you one for you this place is
not gonna know what hit em I'm gonna
roll up and be like hi my ceiling is
missing and I have party supplies and
you're probably going to be expecting
some small child but I know it's me
adults adult party this party cup for
you a cup for you for you it's Robin a
birthday party right now I don't know if
you know or novel we're having a
birthday party and you're all invited
except most of you don't live here so
these are nice cups I'm gonna have to
take them back from the restaurant after
our party oh hello a fancy restaurant
thank you for your plates we don't want
them we want these plates I hope there
is accommodating as I'm hoping that
they're going to be or they're just
gonna think that I'm strange and you
know what I'm okay with
because I'm so so happy I want to let
you know there's Treat Bags in here and
everybody who attends my party will get
a treat bag oh you're a table cover
okay how many treat bags are in here
eight favor bags I think I only have
eight friends so I'm gonna save one of
these treat bags for you guys because I
wanna since I know that all of you
cannot come to my birthday party I would
like to send you a treat bag so follow
me happy birthday and oh just pick
somebody to get to take it three back
buttons
it's what my buttons go and I'm just
gonna put this in my doorway every day
I'm so glad that you're all celebrating
my birthday with me more play more play
more plays I'm an adult I'm an adult
it's my birthday and I'll cry if I want
you do want cry why would I you can cry
I would not cry a little cry tears over
happiness you guys I'm gonna have so
many centerpieces I'm gonna have to send
someone the centerpiece more napkins for
my piggy friends happy birthday to me
it's my birthday I'll cry if I want to
I'll dance if I want to I will do
anything I'll do a run here it is nope
you guys can't even see me I'm just
hiding here doorway curtain I'm opening
this thing up right don't think I want
to be able to bring this to a restaurant
I'm the birthday girl I'm Annabelle oh
my god I might need to make this like my
new set what are you thinking about that
huh thank you so much for we're
celebrating my birthday with me I hope
that you all have a great day and if
it's your birthday today - happy
birthday to you and if your birthday's
tomorrow or a birthday was yesterday or
whatever your birthday is I wish you a
very happy birthday and I hope you have
a fantastic one for my treat bexco all
right I'm gonna go click like for my
birthday
subscribe for my birthday it only comes
around once a year
thank God
I'm here to record okay thinking through
morning oh gosh look at the things in
the Shabbat oh it is over here little
box I'll crop that out okay am I ready
to shoot sure sure him cords hanging out
testing hi hello we ready to roll I
think we ready to roll
talking to no one cuz I'm the only
person in this room let me hear at all -
you guys think it's a little light back
here how does I look good oh are you
ready now just seeing are you ready